yeah we've been talking a lot about
these missile strikes but there's been a
real surge these last few days Russian
motorcycle attacks across the whole of
Ukraine Ukraine claims that 29 and 30
have been shot down you're never quite
sure what the truth is behind that
um but one did get through at Odessa
just down by you it's one of the Russian
missiles struck an industrial facility
there uh Apparently one person died and
two people were badly injured the
ukrainians also claimed they shot down
two armed drones and two reconnaissance
drones as well these Russian missile
attacks came from Land Air and sea but
crucially they also included the kinzao
missile six remember the Hypersonic
missiles that Russia had claimed were
undefeatable but six of those were
involved in shot down as well but it's
not been all one way as part of this uh
um the news on Crimea Russian occupied
Crimea overnight the railway was
derailed as well
um the um apparently some form of
explosion the Russian authorities say
that um that nobody was hurt but that it
was carrying grain but what they have
said suspended all its Railway movements
along that it is worth pointing out that
any Railway on Crimea is vital for
Russian logistics resupply for their war
effort and meanwhile we saw on that map
that there was also strikes on Kiev and
we've as we said in our introduction as
well why are the Russians particularly
targeting Keith
and the only person who will actually
know that obviously would be Putin but
after a 50-day lull there's been a
massive Spike up and for nine days this
month there's been a massive load of
attacks on key normally between the
hours about nine and five thirty in the
morning and it's most disruptive and
although Ukraine has been very
successfully shooting them down the
debris falls down and has caused fires
all over the place as to the why
probably the three main reasons are
probably that Russia's got limited
options to attack Ukraine at the moment
and therefore by firing missiles that
capital is a way of just keeping their
heads down secondly it wants to Russia
wants to distract and disrupt Ukraine as
they try and prepare for their spring
offensive and finally they'll know that
will have a limited supply of their
defense weapons the more they can
saturate them the more they run out it
is worth pointing out as well though
yesterday there was a lot of reports
that one of the Patriot missile systems
the U.S systems that are providing the
umbrella at Keith apparently Russia had
destroyed one so Russia would almost
certainly if they believe that would
have intensified attacks because they
wouldn't they'd known they could get
through it actually looks to be the case
that if it was damaged it was only
lightly damaged and it's actually fully
up and running again so the protective
umbrella is in place and briefly Sean
we've heard a lot about Ukraine asking
for
fighter jets to help defend their
country Rishi sunak the Prime Minister
has offered to train Pilots are we
getting any more details on how that
could impact the raf's training programs
yeah I know we're quite sure of time but
the fact is that the UK doesn't operate
F-16 so we'd have to do flying training
as an opportunity would that impact a
number of Pilots that we put through our
training system probably the answer is
yes three points though first of all
we've got time to expand the training
system so that's an option secondly the
rest of the country is supporting
Ukraine there's compromises everywhere
if that's a compromise the RAF has to
make then so be it the third one this is
actually a coalition of the Willing so
it's not just the UK and the fact the UK
may not provide the platforms because we
don't fly these we do have the oldest
flying training school in the central
offline system at the heart of the royal
Air Force therefore training is undeally
the place that we would take the lead